philippe emmanuel y médecins exerçant en
espagne
philippe emmanueli merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors là
la seconde vague était attendue mais
peut-être pas d'une telle virulence est
ce que vous vous partagez sentiment ce
soir oui alors c'est vrai que moi
j'avais parlé de seconde dès la première
vague et beaucoup ne croyaient pas cette
seconde vague qui est pourtant dans tous
les livres d'infectiologie classique et
donc cette deuxième vague est arrivée
finalement un petit peu comme prévu et
on sait que la deuxième vague est
toujours plus importante d'ailleurs que
la première vague
donc on peut dire que ati mais je ne
suis pas surpris par cette seconde vague
et effectivement nous sommes devant pour
faire face à ce fait à cette seconde
vague
l'espagne veut à la fois éviter à tout
prix art confinement mais en même temps
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire parce que
finalement leur confinement n'est pas
inéluctable
oui si vous voulez c'est tout le
paradoxe de la situation dans laquelle
on se trouve aujourd'hui et le dernier
article du land 7 qui est paru il y à 24
heures sur l'efficacité des mesures de
distanciation sociale ou de confinement
va relancer le débat parce que le land 7
et bien trouve en gros que l'efficacité
des mesures sociales pour baisser le
fameux taux de reproduction du coc id
est d'environ 23%
donc on n'est pas dans des taux non plus
extraordinaire c'est à dire que la
distanciation sociale ne permet pas de
supprimer la contagiosité et c'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui avec toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises jusqu'à
maintenant et qui n'ont pas permis
d'arrêter la reprise importante de cette
contagiosité
c'est cette question du confinement
justement est ce qu'elle est sur la
table aujourd'hui en espagne est ce
qu'on en parle avec des écoles ouvertes
comme en irlande par exemple
oui malheureusement la question du
confinement revient et d'actualité alors
par exemple en catalogne
imaginent de nouvelles formes de
confinement et on a par exemple parlé
d'un confinement qui serait mis en place
uniquement du vendredi au dimanche de
façon effectivement à couper en quelque
sorte la poire en deux pour préserver en
partie les activités économiques
comment ça se passe dans votre cabinet
aujourd'hui vous constatez ce rebond
l'épidémie c'est très concret vous le
voyez tous les jours
alors c'est très intéressant ce qu'il
est les chiffres qu'on en espagne et ce
que nous on peut voir concrètement sur
le terrain est très intéressant parce
que on peut dire quand même que c'est
fondamentalement différent de la
première vague c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement tous les gens qui se
présentent avec des signes je dirais
assimilés à des rhumes wade signe je
dirais relativement léger et bien une
grande majorité d'entre eux reviennent
avec un test positif
donc on peut voir effectivement dans
notre pratique la réalité de
l'importance de la reprise épidémique et
de la contagiosité en revanche par
rapport à la première vague ont envoyé
de façon vraiment très nette
l'importance des tableaux respiratoires
aujourd'hui et bien effectivement tous
les cas qu'on voit sont relativement
bénins
et pour illustrer mon propos je vous est
prévu dans deux petits graphiques pour
vous montrer vraiment comment ça se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans les chiffres
en espagne ça c'est la cour de mortalité
effectivement qu'on pouvait voir lors de
la première vague vous voyez que après
avoir atteint un taux de 2 100 morts par
jour le taux de mortalité est monté en
flèche très très rapidement et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on observe
effectivement en espagne c'est plus une
courbe de ce type là avec une
oscillation entre selon les jours entre
80 et 200 morts
mais en revanche depuis le début de la
deuxième vague on reste finalement dans
une sorte de plateau est ce que la tonte
et bien alors comment s'explique c'est
très intéressant parce qu'il ya en gros
on peut dire qu'il ya deux hypothèses la
première hypothèse c'est simplement
qu'on n'ait à la sortie de l'été et
peut-être qu'il y à un cofacteur
si vous voulez au coville 19 qu'on n'a
pas identifiés et peut-être que quand
c'est ce qu'ont factor ça peut être par
exemple un petit virus virus de la rue
virus du rhume ou quelque chose comme ça
et quand ce qu facteur est présent
peut-être effectivement qu'à ce moment
là
l'épidémie est beaucoup plus mortel et
ça c'est peut-être le risque concours
aujourd'hui c'est à dire effectivement
d'être dans une expansion incroyable de
l'épidémie avec un taux de mortalité qui
est relativement modérée et si ce
potentiel cofacteur arrive et bien à ce
moment là on va se retrouver avec une
mortalité extrêmement importante
ça n'est qu'une hypothèse mais on ne
peut pas expliquer si vous voulez de
façon claire ce différentiel de
mortalité entre la première vague et la
deuxième balle
il ya quand même une deuxième hypothèse
qui est difficile aussi validé parce
qu'on n'a pas les mêmes outils
scientifiques pendant la première et la
deuxième vague
c'est le fait que la distanciation
social aurait permis de limiter la
charge virale est qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui sont contaminés en quelque
sorte en charge virale bien inférieures
à celles de la première vague et qu'à ce
moment là ils développent des formes
beaucoup moins grave et que finalement
au fond cette cette expansion de la
pandémie se fait finalement avec un coût
en terme de mortalité moins important
merci beaucoup
philippe emmanueli pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes médecin français
exerçant en espagne